in the last episode of developer Diaries
we told you about how physics in the
world of tanks will change in 2014 today
we'll tell you about the upcoming
changes in graphics in brief everything
will become more detailed clearer and
more realistic
what is the most important feature in a
game bought tanks of course the tanks
and other vehicles when World of Tanks
came out vehicle models had about 8,000
polygons a limiting factor was the
performance capacity of personal
computers of that time more vehicles
have been introduced as time has gone by
the newer models are more detailed some
of the models in the game today have
twice as many polygons up to 18,000
however the graphical details of
vehicles are about to improve
significantly when the graphical upgrade
is implemented typical models will have
50,000 polygons all the most complex
ones will have 100,000 polygons what is
the advantage of so many polygons well
you probably remember those octagonal
wheels or diagonal gun barrels these
shapes were the result of low polygon
counts hi polygonum detailing is needed
to smooth all the roundish surfaces to
the point where they don't resemble a
pencil animal at some point the constant
improvement in model quality started
becoming a problem there are hundreds of
vehicles in the game so remaking vehicle
models in order to meet the current
performance capacity of personal
computers threatened to become a
never-ending process this is why it was
also decided to change the technology of
model building itself now we use a
process called normal mapping what is
normal mapping roughly speaking an ideal
model of the vehicle is built first it
has millions of polygons then this model
is optimized to the point that
present-day video cards are able to
process it once these millions of
polygons are baked in a texture the
quality of details will be
indistinguishable from real geometry and
the load on video cards will be much
less objects will be more realistic not
only due to an increased number of
polygons an advanced texture mapping
system will be introduced as well the
underlying goal of the new material
model is to let players understand the
size and weight of the vehicles to give
you that feeling that your tank is a
massive chunk of metal just by looking
at them everyone should feel the weight
of these monsters when artists create
materials for objects they work with
photographs as well as with real
patterns if there
available now with the transition to HD
artists have a new tool to show some
unique features of certain vehicle
textures we use a 3d scanner joints
texture small details everything is
transferred onto the in-game model of
the vehicle scanning allows making those
vehicles that have never existed in
metal look more authentic we have a set
of texture for each nation thus the
texture of cast turret of a Soviet tank
is different than for example the
texture of an American tank now we can
construct the look of the vehicles that
existed only on paper with maximum
accuracy we do this by applying the
armor texture of that nation the correct
time period in the factory where an
experimental vehicle was expected to be
built and produced if the vehicle had
been produced it probably would have
looked like this creation of vehicle
external appearance has become less and
less the result of creative work it has
become more a result of a meticulous
reconstruction in some cases our
vehicles look more like the real
vehicles of their time than examples of
those vehicles sitting in museums some
details of the museum vehicles may be
missing they also may be reconstructed
in accurately or incorrectly scuff marks
on paint or the way the thin vehicle
panels become deformed these details
create the atmosphere of realism to
create them we studied how combat
vehicles wear out a tank should look
like a tank that is being actively used
is thinking about us coming historians
have told us about the crew how and
where crew members would move and what
they would carry with them what would
you to its duncombe well
thus we know where tankers would likely
scuff tank armor to shine hug the
obvious along with the appearance of new
vehicle models the world around them
will change as well the new system of
texture mapping will be applied not only
to new vehicle models buildings surfaces
water and rocks everything will look
more realistic we're giving special
attention to the atmosphere on the maps
we want a player who for example waits
in an ambush for an enemy vehicle and
notice and enjoy the details of the
scenery no effects will be added into
the game while existing ones will be
remade now we're working on improving
the quality of textures that we use to
create effects like smoke and fire if a
tank is burning bursting flame will bend
around some features of tank
construction flames will curl around
other projecting tank parts effects make
a long and complicated journey from
artists to players because they are not
evaluated only in terms of aesthetics
all effects must be approved by the art
director first as they should fit the
general environment then they are
approved by game designers because
effect should not interfere with the
game process and after that the QA
department has to make sure that affects
don't reduce the number of frame per
second night maps extremely thick smoke
from destroyed vehicles and other
effects failed to pass all these tests
however the features that did make it
into the game look really interesting
now we're working on adding more wind to
our affects not only to the effects but
to the game setting in general
to show some unique ambience on some
maps was a bit static before the
environment and World of Tanks is about
to become livelier trees and grass will
respond not only to wind but also to
shell explosions shots and movement of
tracks will raise clouds of dust seasons
will change weather will vary now we're
experimenting with server-side
visibility that will depend on what the
weather is at the given time we want it
to be dynamic it's not as if visibility
range has to be a perfect 600 meters
except on maps where it's constantly
snowing so that visibility range is
always 300 metres for example visibility
can be good until a heavy snow sets in
five minutes after the start of the
battle and five minutes later the snow
stops no one will know when exactly it
will happen because it will be triggered
by a server command a dust storm or a
downpour can start suddenly either one
will drastically reduce visibility range
we've told you about major upcoming
changes in World of Tanks graphics
follow the news and updates we've got
more interesting things to tell you this
year good luck on the battlefield
you